el humo de las bengalas tiñe el puerto
de sant marc o este viernes de buena
mañana una decena de embarcaciones
francesas echó el ancla para evitar que
los ferrys británicos se acerquen al
muelle durante una hora de bloqueo solo
llega un barco de carga proveniente de
hershey un ambiente amigable y para dar
la bienvenida a la nave británica
las banderas bretona y francesa en sal
malo ya levantaron el bloqueo pero los
pescadores de caleta tomaron el relevo
para que los barcos ingleses no puedan
acercarse hasta el puerto
es más que nada una acción simbólica
para que el gobierno británico reaccione
si no hay mejoras mostraremos los
dientes
los pescadores franceses reclaman más
firmeza por parte del elíseo en las
negociaciones de las licencias de pesca
con downing street
más de 150 marineros todavía no han
recibido los permisos para pescar en
aguas británicas como emanuel posee que
se felicita por esta movilización casi
nunca antes habíamos visto esto todos
los puertos están movilizados esto basta
bretaña es que nos afecta a todos
acciones contundentes para presionar en
las negociaciones a primera hora de la
tarde los pescadores bloquearon los
ferrys que salen desde west ham también
cerraron las inmediaciones del túnel que
cruza el canal de la mancha por donde
transita el 25% del flujo comercial
entre reino unido y europa